german chancellor angela merkel has
defended her handling of the pandemic in
a speech
in germany's parliament she said that
lockdown measures
would have been effective but new
variants of the coronavirus mean
infection numbers are rising across
europe she said that germany is
currently relying on mass
testing to try to control its third wave
of infections
and urge germans to take up the offer of
free rapid testing frustration
has been growing over the slow vaccine
rollout
but merkel said it was right that the eu
decided to acquire
and authorize vaccines jointly despite
all the difficulties it was right
decide to jointly acquire and authorize
vaccines in the european union we see
there are some slight differences
in the distribution and there are huge
debates about this but what would happen
if some of the countries had a vaccine
others did not i cannot imagine it
because it would shake the very
foundations
of the union
well joining me now are chief political
correspondent melody crane here in the
studio and our political correspondent
thomas sparrow is down
at the german bonus title let's start
with you melinda we heard angela merkel
there defending the eu
joint procurement policy when it deals
to vaccines did she
offer a convincing defense of that what
do you make of it
i think she's right that had germany
gone it alone
at that stage it would indeed have
shaken europe to its very foundations
because we would have seen
some powerful countries like germany
with adequate vaccine
and then undoubtedly others smaller
countries that don't have a lot of
bargaining power in international
pharma markets uh possibly without
vaccine so i think she's right on that
point
the problem is brussels did not
adequately go
into crisis mode when they then began to
look at negotiations with the big
drug makers they essentially haggled
over
price over liability rather than seeing
that in a crisis
time is of the absolute essence
and germany also bears some
responsibility here because germany
as europe's biggest economic power did
not
throw the full force of its expertise
and negotiating skills
at brussels disposal essentially germany
stood back
and let brussels handle this in a
rather typically brussels bureaucratic
fashion and so i think
if we look at the procurement process
mistakes were made
and berlin does ultimately also bear
some responsibility for that
and it should be said that uh that
germany had the eu
presidency when much of this was being
negotiated um
thomas it's the the slow rollout of the
vaccine
is of course an issue but it's not the
only thing angel america talked about
in her in her speech today uh she's
being criticized for the government's
handling of the pandemic in general how
did
she respond to that criticism in her
speech
angela merkel stressed once again as she
did earlier in the week that this is a
new kind of pandemic in particular
because of the
more contagious coronavirus variants but
at the same time she stressed that
germany now has at its disposal
other elements to fight that new
pandemic as
if you compare it with the earlier
stages of the coronavirus pandemic and
she specifically mentioned
testing you mentioned that as well terry
she mentioned again germany's vaccine
rollout which
has been very slow but is progressing
she mentioned the fact that in april
germany will receive a high number of
vaccines which will help to speed up the
process as well as the inclusion of gps
and family doctors in the whole vaccine
distribution and she also once again
defended the use of the coronavirus
warn app which was very useful for
germany in the first wave of the
pandemic in particular for its track and
trace
policy but which has been criticized in
recent months
for people who consider it not very
useful when it comes to germany's fight
against the coroner virus angela merkel
also stressed that it is not possible to
simply only highlight the negative
aspects of
policy and that's why she also focus on
those important issues that germany has
at its disposal to fight the coronavirus
pandemic
did the chancellor offer any new ideas
thomas for
how to deal with the rising infection
numbers
terry no because i don't think this is
the venue for angela merkel to present
new ideas these kinds of government
speeches ahead of
eu summits are normally intended to
present broader elements of policy
which can then lead to a discussion here
in in parliament
so as such what we heard today from
angela merkel was some of those key
elements that the government both
regional and federal governments have
put in practice in recent months to try
and fight
the pandemic angela merkel once again
stressed that cautious reopening plan
that was agreed on earlier
this month in one of those 20 meetings
that have taken place as the coronavirus
pandemic began at
the german chancery between regional and
federal leaders and that cautious
reopening plan is one
that she again defended as part of
germany's overall policy to fight the
pandemic
thomas thank you very much that was
thomas sparrow down at the bundestag
and here in the studio our chief
political correspondent melinda crane
thank you very much
you